美国超级散户Wincent Designo在过去的24个月里就靠着一套简单的突破回踩策略,就从市场里拿走了接近100万美金。
就算去年这么反复无偿的行情,他也是实现了40多万美金的收益。
都说大到质减,但是真正敢只用最基础的方法在市场里以此为生的人非常少见。
他说他的策略很多人都会,但是99%的人都用不好。
大部分人交易亏钱不是因为策略问题,而是因为他们根本分不清什么是真正的回踩,也分不清什么是陷阱。
能赚钱的秘密不在于攻,而在于守
有些细节能让他避开绝大多数的假突破
而这些是很少有人讲的
接下来,我就把他这套突破回踩结合
自指数公正的策略泄露给各位
哪怕你是个交易老手
这次也绝对会让你对突破交易有一个全新的认识
首先我们要纠正一个做法
很多人做突破总是被套的原因是他们总是在追高
经常一突破就要开单
那样被套住的概率非常高
因为真突破往往只有一次
假突破却有很多
那是给散户准备的踏空恐惧陷阱
成功率很低
所以我们不再突破k线买入
而是在回踩关键位置的时候
再考虑买入
这里的关键位置只有两个
第一个是前一日的高点区域
第二个是前一日的低点区域
这是多头和空头的关键位置进入多头的规则是首先是标注关键位置也就是前的高点区域,然后等价格突破。价格必须强势突破关键位后再回落。
我们就可以打开两分钟或五分钟图表,等价格回踩的同时,观察这个整体的上涨形态是否是一个标准的牛旗形态,并且是否在关键位附近出现了长下影线的拒绝行为。
当一根阳线吞没了前面的阴线
又突破了这个牛旗上沿的时候
条件就全部满足
这根突破K线就是我们要找的关键K线
关键K线的收盘价就是我们的入场点位
如果价格收盘跌回关键位下方
就要立刻止损
可以自己设定一个小缓冲区
跌破就说明突破失败
如果离上一个突破高点的盈亏比超过1
就可以在价格触及这个位置的时候
只赢25%到50%的仓位
如果盈亏比不足
又可以等到一个关键阻力位时平掉部分仓位
剩下的可以拿住博取更高的收益
看这个例子
我们先标记出前一日的高点区域作为关键位
可以看到关键位在百元整数位附近
这种位置的市场情绪一般都比较亢奋
这时不要进场
等价格冲高回落后
再切换到两分钟图表
当价格走出标准的牛旗形态
并且收出带有长下影线的K线
我们才可以认为之前的阻力已经变成了支撑
有多头在护盘
当价格突破这个牛旗的上延时就可以入场做多止损设置在影线低点下方或之前标记的关键位下方因为盈亏比没超过1所以不能在上一个突破的高点附近止盈
至少要拿到1盈亏比以上
进入空头的规则相反
首先是标注前一日的低点区域作为关键位
然后等价格跌破
价格必须强势跌破关键位后再反弹
当重新接近关键位附近时
我们就可以打开两分钟图表
观察这个整体的下跌走势
是否是一个标准的雄奇形态
当关键位附近出现了长上影线的拒绝后
又有阴线吞没了前面的阳线
同时还跌破了这个熊旗下沿
就满足了做空要求
这根跌破K线就是我们要找的关键K线
我们就可以在关键K线的收盘价入场空单
如果价格收盘反弹回了关键位上方
就要立刻止损
可以自己设定一个小缓冲区
价格回去就说明了跌破失败
如果离上一个低点的盈亏比超过1
就可以在触及这个位置的时候只赢25%到50%的仓位
如果盈亏比不足
就可以等到一个合适的强支撑位平掉一部分
这套策略不难
但实际用的时候还是很容易出现亏损
因为还少了两个关键的过滤条件
也就是四指数背离的时候不做
震荡的时间不做
四指数分别指的是纳指标普3Q和SPY
四指数背离也就是常说的SMT背离原理通过同时观察四指数的走势关系比如这些本应该同步走强的指数出现了不同步的走势或者其中几个面临强阻力区就容易形成SMT背离
这往往意味着当前趋势可能正在衰竭
市场存在反转或回调的风险
Wincent说
他就因为忽略了四指数共振
单独用突破回踩策略亏了不少钱
记得非常清楚的一次是
当时纳指突破了盘前的高点
并且看起来已经站稳
正在做一个突破回踩动作
但其实同一时间
标普500指数没能突破前高
反而在碰到高点时被打下来
形成了一个双顶的拒绝形态
这就是典型的背离
之后标普的下跌把纳指也拖下水
快速地跌破了支撑位
它也被迫止损离场
这里的标普不仅是没有跟上
还处在了它定义的震荡不交易区
它的不交易区指的是前一日高点和盘前低点的中间区
和前一日低点和盘前高点的中间区
这个区间的价格走势非常无序
方向不明确
波动又很小
非常容易被来回止损
到这里如果你已经在考虑使用这套策略
一定先把逻辑吃透
然后打开TradingView图表的回放功能
在你经常做的品种复盘
看看过去几个月的行情的运行情况
对策略的长期运行情况心中有数
好了
娱乐节目没有任何投资建议
检查一下是否已经点击订阅
以免错过更加有利可图的交易策略
祝你早安
午安
晚安
拜拜